More and more, Hollywood studios are confident
enough in a film's ability to launch a franchise
that they'll start planning for sequels even
before viewers have seen the movie.
However, if the film doesn't perform as well
as expected at the box office, or is panned
by critics and viewers alike, studios are
forced to change those plans.
In these cases, sequels may be entirely abandoned,
leaving audiences to wonder what could have
been.
Here are Screen Rant's 10 movie sequels you
will never see.
Green Lantern
Ryan Reynolds may have found the perfect superhero
role in Deadpool, but comic book fans will
never forget the disappointment of his turn
as the DC hero Green Lantern.
Warner Bros. gave director Martin Campbell
a $200 million budget hoping to launch a DC
Comics franchise rivalling Marvel's burgeoning
cinematic universe.
However, when the movie barely turned a profit
and disappointed both comic book fans and
casual audiences, Warner Bros. scrapped plans
for the sequel.
Although we'll never see a Green Lantern sequel
starring Reynolds, the studio has planned
a new take on the superhero as part of the
DC Extended Universe.
Battlefield Earth
Based on Scientology founder L. Ron Hubbard's
book of the same name, this John Travolta
pet project only covered the first half of
the source material; the filmmakers planned
to tackle the second half of the novel in
a sequel.
But, those plans were cancelled when Battlefield
Earth bombed at the box office, resulting
in a $40 million loss for producers - including
Travolta who starred in the film and used
his own money to partially fund its production.
Because of its box office failure and all-around
poor movie-going experience, Battlefield Earth
has earned a reputation as one of the worst
movies in film history.
Superman Returns
Before DC Comics' famous superhero received
the reboot treatment with Zack Snyder's Man
of Steel, director Bryan Singer and star Brandon
Routh brought the Man of Tomorrow to life
in Superman Returns.
However, the film received criticism for focusing
too much on the emotional side of the character
without giving Superman enough action sequences
of him taking on bad guys.
As a result, Warner Bros. pulled the plug
on a second film helmed by Singer.
The director has since talked about his plans
for the sequel, which included the villain
Darkseid and the movie being titled The Man
of Steel.
But, with Henry Cavill playing the superhero
in the DC Extended Universe, this is one superhero
sequel we won't ever see.
The Golden Compass
Based on the first book in Philip Pullman's
His Dark Materials trilogy, The Golden Compass
was set up to be the next massively popular
young adult fantasy series, like a cross between
Harry Potter, Lord of the Rings, and The Chronicles
of Narnia.
However, because the movie underperformed
at the North American box office and the film's
overseas rights were sold by New Line Cinema,
the studio didn't make as much money as expected
on The Golden Compass's $180 million budget.
As a result, they cancelled plans to adapt
the second book in the series, The Subtle
Knife.
Though fans won't ever see a sequel to The
Golden Compass, BBC is reportedly developing
a television series based on His Dark Materials.
Fantastic Four: Rise of the Silver Surfer
Although 2005's Fantastic Four was a goofy
take on Marvel's first family, the film performed
well enough at the box office to earn a sequel.
However, the same can't be said for Fantastic
Four: Rise of the Silver Surfer, which didn't
earn as much as the first movie.
So, although the actors behind the titular
superhero team had signed three-picture deals
and many of the filmmakers were prepared to
return, Fox pulled the plug on a third instalment
in the series.
Instead, the movie studio rebooted the Fantastic
Four in 2015 - to disastrous results.
Fantastic Four
After the underperformance of Fantastic Four:
Rise of the Silver Surfer, Fox brought in
director Josh Trank to reboot Marvel's first
family with a younger cast and a darker, more
grounded tone.
However, disputes between Trank and Fox arose
during production, leading to reshoots for
Fantastic Four that overhauled the entire
second half of the film.
The movie became the worst reviewed Marvel
movie to date and even Trank publicly condemned
the final cut.
Following the overwhelmingly negative response
to Fantastic Four, Fox pulled the planned
sequel from their release schedule, effectively
canceling the second instalment in this rebooted
franchise.
Dredd
Following comic character Judge Dredd, played
by Karl Urban, this sci-fi action film was
a box office failure despite a generally positive
critical response to the movie's exciting
action beats.
Dredd has since earned cult film status because
of its dedicated and vocal fans base, which
have been calling for a sequel for many years.
According to Urban and producer Adi Shankar,
talks of Dredd 2 did happen around 2014, but
the film's screenwriter Alex Garland has since
urged fans to give up hope on a second instalment
- even if Dredd does deserve that sequel.
The Amazing Spider-Man 2
Prior to its release, Sony Pictures had scheduled
two more films in its Amazing Spider-Man series
with Andrew Garfield as the titular hero.
The Amazing Spider-Man 2 was meant to establish
a cinematic universe that would rival Marvel
Studios - with Sony planning to include Sinister
Six and Venom spinoffs.
However, The Amazing Spider-Man 2's mixed
critical response and underperformance at
the box office led the studio to rethink their
plans.
The bad situation was exacerbated by the 2014
Sony Pictures Entertainment hack, which saw
leaked emails of negotiations with Marvel
to have Spider-Man return home.
A few months later, Sony and Marvel's partnership
on a rebooted Spider-Man franchise was officially
announced, with Tom Holland later revealed
to play the web-slinger in Captain America:
Civil War.
This move effectively canceled plans for any
sequel to The Amazing Spider-Man 2.
Batman & Robin
Following the success of Tim Burton's two
Batman films, director Joel Schumacher stepped
in for Batman Forever and its sequel, Batman
& Robin.
During the production of Batman & Robin, Warner
Bros. gave the green light for another instalment
in the series that would see Schumacher return
as director.
Titled Batman Triumphant, George Clooney,
Chris O'Donnell and Alicia Silverstone were
set to reprise their roles as Batman, Robin,
and Batgirl respectively.
Plus, reportedly, Schumacher had also approached
Nicolas Cage to play Batman villain Scarecrow.
However, due to the negative critic and fan
response to Batman & Robin, as well as its
underperformance at the box office, Warner
Bros. cancelled Batman Triumphant.
The Dark Knight wouldn't be seen on the big
screen again until Christopher Nolan's Batman
Begins.
The Mortal Instruments: City of Bones
After the success of other young adult novels
adapted to blockbuster franchises like The
Hunger Games, Constantin Films brought the
first book in Cassandra Clare's Mortal Instruments
series to life.
A few months before the movie hit theaters,
the production company announced a film based
on the second book City of Ashes, would begin
production in September 2013 - only a month
after City of Bones was to be released.
Although the film opened below expectations,
Constantin remained confident it would warrant
a sequel because of increasing book and soundtrack
sales.
But, when City of Bones continued to underperform
at the box office, production on City of Ashes
was delayed.
Any remaining hope that the sequel would be
made at all was officially squashed when Constantin
announced they would be moving forward with
a new television adaptation called Shadowhunters
that has since premiered on Freeform.
So what do you think of our list?
Did we miss any cancelled sequels of your
favorite movies?
Let us know in our comment section and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.